all right it's the morning after the
Conor McGregor vs. khabib nurmagomedov
fight I'm hungover I've got a headache
we did the livestream it was amazing but
the fight didn't go the way I wanted it
to
obviously I'm a mcgregor farm being a
conor mcgregor fan makes a lot of people
instantly dislike you as if you're not
your automatic prick and I am a prick
but for completely different reasons to
be an economy Gregor fine just ask some
of my ex-girlfriends you know I mean but
at least get to know as before you make
your mind up and then you can call as a
prick anyway but you know Conor McGregor
fine you get called so many things like
your farm boy dick radar casual which
apparently means you don't watch every
single your sea fight ever and therefore
you know you don't know anything and to
be honest with you I've been watching
your sea for 15 years but people
automatically think because I'm not
Jorgen or not one of these you know
former fighters I don't deserve an
opinion well here I am I've got an
opinion and I'm pretty pissed off with
our last night to be honestly I think
McGregor maybe could have won that fight
but he just came in a million miles away
but I want to start off by giving credit
to khabib he fought a world-class
performance last night he took out one
of the best fighters we've seen in
recent times in the UFC and did it
comfortably he was a cardio machine
his wrestling was perfect he got that
loss single when he needed to and he
kept McGregor down and grounded him out
withstood the dangerous rounds at
McGregor house in and took him into deep
water and struggled them it was
world-class inside the cage outside the
cage he was a [__] prick but we'll
get to that I feel like the best
McGregor we see is the one who respects
his opponents ability the one who fought
innately as the second time the one who
fought Eddie Alvarez who's light on his
feet aware that he can be hit doesn't
want to get caught up in any danger and
is in and out very smart fighter there's
another McGregor who fought Chad Mendes
didn't show him any respect nearly paid
the price the one who fought neatly as
the first time didn't show many respect
did pay the price and and even in
Mayweather like going out and unloading
on him in the first three rounds when he
could have you know tried to
counter-attack and things like that he
just he tries to walk through people and
when he tries to do that if they're
tough as nails like Kabir clearly is
McGregor's in trouble in that first
round
khabib got the law single it was
fantastic
Gregor did well to stay on his feet for
as long as possible but eventually the
takedown came but could be achieved
nothing but what he did do without
damaging McGregor is suck the gust
hanged a new tick Oh Gregor's most
powerful best round he has where he
finishes most of his opponents smart by
khabib he's 10 seconds oh yeah he hasn't
achieved a significant strike yet
there's no damage being done to McGregor
but the gas tank has been 3 and a little
bit but not not really a great deal in
the second round
McGregor stand in their arms by his side
no respect for Kirby whatsoever and
khabib cracks him with another hand
right and Conor McGregor looks Rock and
I'm sitting there thinking what are you
doing you do want to lose this fight
like treat the guy with respect and to
be fair to McGregor that would have
dropped most fighters and not most
fighters out it was a hell of a punch
what a chin McGregor must have on him
and he stayed in there for the end of
the road book for me that punch was the
beginning of the end for McGregor
because once Kabir sought to win in any
of the standup when that is supposed to
be the the peace of the fight where he
is most out of his depth whereas
McGregor golf from here could be takes
him down and grinds him out for the end
of that round and and at that point
everyone around the table we're all
sitting there going well unless it not
out happens this is could be a fight now
I expected the McGregor who was on his
tours against Alvarez become a
flat-footed hands down not a care in the
world
throwing kicks he's a wrestler me do you
want to hand him the [__] take yeah
this is not the McGregor I expected to
see really the first two rounds have
gone exactly the way Cubs team would
have wanted them do as a McGregor fund
the third run was pretty painful to
watch because his energy levels were
gone the snap in his punches wasn't
there and his timing that is normally
perfect was off his setups to trick
khabib and leaving himself wide open
weren't forthcoming it was basic from
Connor and
was the luck of power was there khabib
is actually welcoming the footman
punches and at that point you're like
wow khabib is brick and connor down
mentally he's welcoming it on and for
all connor you know look okay and landed
some okay punches it was nowhere near
the level that we've seen him at and
some people will put that down to how
good khabib is and i certainly would but
I'd also say McGregor just didn't look
ready for this fight and maybe the time
off did hurt and but regardless could be
you could say he was winning this
[__] fight at that point I don't know
I've never I've never seen this kind of
wrestling before this daghestani style
wrestling it's like it's weight
management its technique it's not
strength to it the weight corner whoops
you want where left-handers we could be
walking on it would take down now in the
fourth round the finished km khabib gets
the trip on McGregor maneuvers his body
round locks to the choke in after trying
a few different things and struggles
from the gregor and I was unsure whether
he was actually gonna let him go because
the blood is so bad between these two
like I think was herb Dean had like
restrained khabib a bit after he pushed
him off him it was pure hatred and you
know you're thinking McGregor looks in
his eyes a little bit like alright let's
just let this go here you know it's all
over but could be it wasn't over and
when he looks at Dillon darkness and
some of the team McGregor and throws us
gum shield yeah like [__] me he's still
pissed we were saying shades of Brock
lesner UFC 100 and it get worse outta
nowhere could be jumps the [__] cage
he's fly and kicking into Dillon Dennis
who wasn't people saying he's welcoming
I don't think Dillon Tannis by the
footage I've seen even was aware that
that was going to happen at all and next
thing you know there's a [__]
full-blown brawl in the crowd it's all
team to be the [__] [__]
and that was that was bad but for me
what was really bad is an already ruined
Conor McGregor is getting set upon by a
Cubs training partners Connor has to
throw a punch just to defend himself as
someone's coming straight at him and
then someone comes from behind paying
not all into the side of the dome Joe
Rogan said this is the nastiest I've
ever seen in a fight get in the UFC and
people said that this was fake [__] off
there's nothing thing about this this is
real [__] hatred I've had fighters
they would be my favourite fight I'd be
beaten before and admire the other guy
when lyoto machida was not clean out by
Shogun it was tough when Cain Velasquez
destroyed Brock Lesnar as I thought it
was a fan of these guys but you would
might I mean Cain Velasquez then were
not to become one of me favorite is
after that it was so close less and a
lot of people are gonna be like well
look at what Connor did with the boss in
it and you know I completely think that
Connor was an awful for what you did at
the boss but by then I was already a fan
of him and for khabib personally to act
like this I can't become a fan of his
it's you've already beaten the [__] out
of the guy what more do you want to do
what what you trying to prove me like
the best thing you could have done is be
like yeah I'll take the moral high
ground I'm better than you you it was
there you had it and you've just thrown
it away and made yourself look a
complete [__] prick and for the sport
it's a bad day because you know from a
financial point of view it's bad for the
USA when McGregor loses but more so when
you've got that kind of publicity after
John Jones and people like that have
dried the company through the mud they
just made it look like a complete [__]
you know a lot of people are gonna say
this is sour grapes from me i salty and
all that I'm a [__] grown ass man
like literally I I've come to accept
that your favorite [__] team and
fight I will lose and this isn't about
that this is just to be went on like a
[__] dick
and it's got to be said you know I
thought some people's comments after the
fact like Daniel Cormier bringing up
what had happened in the past or
whatever you know trying to justify it
it wasn't a good look general I mean
like this should just be denounced by
everyone equally the bus incident should
be denounced but that was that was then
you know I mean we denounced that then
and we're denouncing this now it's it
you can't compare the two it's not fair
to the victims of the bus incident and
this isn't fate of the victims of this
incident they're two separate things and
the people involved McGregor has to take
responsibility for the bus khabib should
be taking responsibility now it sounds
like he's apologizing it will be
interesting to say all the us a deal
with him
as for what's next for these two I think
khabib could go on to be the lightweight
Fadel he's so good and it's scary and I
underestimated how much she did have
improved his stand up and clearly connor
underestimated as well which is probably
why could be able look better than he
was because connor wasn't given them
that respect but regardless the man's an
animal us for mcgregor normally in the
past I've demanded rematch as I've
thought we've seen enough in that Nate
first fight to warrant a second fight
and we've seen enough in its career in
O'Connor could probably beat him we
haven't seen anything so far that really
says Conor McGregor can be could be
and I noticed Coach Cavanaugh of the
gregor's team said afterwards you know
on to the next one
I'm not a true Dan the past sort of yeah
makes sense you know win lose or draw
the they're on to the next one not for
this one now this this jeopardizes
everything because when you go in
against Mayweather and you lose fair
enough he's a world-class box r50 and
all usually first have a fight not this
time this legitimizes every criticism
anyone has ever had of Conor McGregor's
career he's a quitter
he doesn't have called you after two
rounds you know the wrestling every
criticism anyone's ever said about
McGregor that we felt it being kind of
unsaid in the chad mendes fight in other
fights they've just been legitimized and
if McGregor wants to go down as the
greatest of all time and if some people
might think that's even crazy me even
saying that but
you know if he goes on beats khabib I
think that's a fair chance of him being
that he has to go and do that he has to
be khabib and there's work to be done
but as everyone who's watching this
video probably already knows when one of
your favorite fighters loses it sucks
donkey dick and I'll not be looking
forward to rewatching that fight anytime
soon
but nevertheless I've given this fight a
lot of time and attention I've really
tried to cover it as best I could so if
you've enjoyed that make sure you
subscribe because I'm gonna be doing
more boxing more football more fighting
MMA the whole lot and yeah I appreciate
everyone who's being stalked by watching
the videos hit the like button thanks
for watching and I'll see us later